welcome to our fifth week of shaping
the future of work my name is Christine
Reardon and I'm a PhD student here at
the Institute for work and employment
research at MIT I'm filling in for
professor Koken this morning who you
will hear from later in the week there
are two items we want to highlight as we
start this week of the course one is our
upcoming topic regarding worker voice
and good quality jobs in the context of
changing forms of work the second is
something we're really excited about
which is a simulated negotiation over
the future social contract at work
something that you will be participating
in next week and which really brings all
of the ideas in this course together in
a very concrete way so this week we're
going to get you set up for that
negotiation but first our focus on work
or voice and advocacy so last week we
heard from a number of individuals about
new arrangements and forms of work
whether it be new patterns of job growth
the organization of work through
technology or new strategies and
entrepreneurship from the discussion
boards these seem to be topics that
resonate with your thinking about the
future of work not only in terms of your
own jobs or careers but also in the
bigger picture of the labor market
within this realm the issue of job
quality is front and center so these two
themes changing forms of work and good
employment practices are critical to our
upcoming module on worker voice on
advocacy we're going to extend this
discussion to consider how work or voice
and organizing are changing as new forms
of organizing work are emerging to do so
we're going to first discuss the decline
in union membership a traditional means
of exercising voice on the job will
identify some of the ways in which new
work arrangements are challenging voice
and job quality will then talk about how
new forms of worker organizing are
starting to adapt to these changes and
challenges firms as we'll see are also
making decisions and how they integrate
new ways of doing work such as those
brought by technology in ways that
maintain good
job standards however we want to take a
moment to emphasize an important point
that puts these discussions in a broader
context in a number of our videos and
discussions we've talked about
alternative work arrangements such as
freelancing or contracting and on demand
or Giga jobs according to a recent study
by US economist lawrence cats and alan
krueger such alternative arrangements
have grown most notably in the last ten
years and now account for about fifteen
percent of workers jobs throughout the
u.s. this growth and the visibility of
arrangements like those of the on-demand
economy are bringing renewed attention
to related labor market challenges still
some of these arrangements make up a
relatively small portion of jobs the
on-demand economy for instance accounted
for less than one percent of total
employment in 2015 according to captain
Krueger so given this there are really
two tasks at hand in this week's agenda
one as we've stated is to understand
emerging forms of voice that overcome
some of the challenges in these
arrangements in our videos an additional
resource section you'll see inspiring
examples and accounts of how change is
being achieved the second task is to
critically examine what these new
challenges are telling us about the
overall labor market encouragingly we
have arrived at a point where we are
engaging in public discourse about
issues like the rights of independent
contractors with on-demand companies
like uber or TaskRabbit one way to think
about this discourse is that it provides
a window or way in to thinking about the
challenges found throughout the labor
market and experienced by workers across
the board whether in an alternative
arrangement or not so given this the
question we ask becomes how can we take
the ideas and the proposals and lessons
we learn from these emerging forms and
use those to think critically about
solutions to challenges and the need for
a stronger role of worker voice across
different segments of the labour market
like those discussed by bureau of labor
statistics chief economist Heidi sure
hopes last week doing so places are
thinking in the trajectory we've been on
throughout this course which has focused
in recent weeks on the gradual demise of
labor market institutions and the social
contract at work we're excited to see
how you're thinking about these in the
discussion boards over the coming week
now on to the negotiation exercise in
week six you'll be engaging with your
course colleagues in dialogue regarding
different actions and employment
practices that can serve as building
blocks for the new social contract at
work to do this you'll be assigned to
groups and will negotiate from the
perspective of a given role including
management labor unions and professional
groups the federal government or
educational institutions the idea behind
this is to bring all of our lessons and
material together in a concrete way but
one that hinges on your creativity and
participation so the outcome of the
exercise is really dependent upon having
as many perspectives and participants as
possible this week you're given basic
information and instructions for the
negotiation you're also asked to sign up
for the exercise and fill out a short
preparation survey we encourage all of
you whether you're taking the class for
a certificate or not to participate so
that we can collectively really make the
most out of this opportunity to think
creatively about the issues we care
about next week you'll receive your role
in your group assignments and will start
your negotiations on our discussion
board you'll notice a new thread
entitled negotiation exercise where this
week and next you can post questions or
let us know if you need assistance we
hope that you'll join us for the
exercise and for a live event
presentation in week 7 the details of
which will post soon there will talk
about your plans for action so stay
tuned